all right
one two three four five one two three
four five okay everyone's good great
Ed is not taking any questions he's
gonna just do a yeah
I was gonna make a statement he's not
taking questions we have hard copies of
the statement we can hand out to you
after the fact
um and then that'll be it for him if
anyone wants to talk to any of the
lawyers you can let me know and if
that's
yeah sure one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten mike check one two
good do I sound professional like I know
what I'm doing
[Laughter]
thank you all right if you've got
questions let me know thank you
citizens
okay where's my my guide Fox Fox News
okay oh there you are okay great
you should speak um tell us about your
experience
um it was really interesting being part
of the judicial process and like serving
on a jury I thought it was really like
both sides had great lawyers and did a
great job and it was a very interesting
case so it was nice to serve
I was on the jury yeah
yes
um we thought really long and hard about
the questions that were presented to us
and it was a really great group of
people who we talked you know we worked
through everything as we were instructed
to by the judge and by the jury
instructions that we were given and we
ultimately came to what we thought was
the right interpretation of the law that
we were given
I mean it's obviously cool to have
anyone play music in front of you live
um so that was like you know an
interesting surprise it's interesting
case because you're comparing music to a
sheet but it was very cool hearing him
here and hear him sing in court I guess
I guess the most important thing in our
decision was that um we had very
we were given the things we were
supposed to consider and we had the
evidence that was given to us and only
that to work with and we had to answer
the questions that we were given which
ultimately led to the judge's judgment
or that we were given so I mean key
factors were
obviously the song
as we're allowed to hear it and then the
deposit copy which was in question and
trying to use their testimonies and the
expert Witnesses expertise in the
subject to try and best understand
the similarities or lack the robber
differences in the two works and try and
make our just best and most Fair
judgment with what we were given
um
I mean I mean I definitely don't think
it was a case where you walk in the room
and you know no one had anything to say
we spent a lot of time going very
carefully through the questions and the
definitions of everything in them and
trying to answer them to the best of our
abilities so I think it was less about
there being a lack of Liberation and
more so of us wanting to be really
thorough and get ourselves on a page
that we were all very comfortable with
which didn't necessarily you know happen
immediately so there was a lot of a lot
of back and forth we all just wanted to
make sure we were very comfortable with
the decision that we were giving
um I think you know there are there's
seven people in the room so everyone had
opinions going in
um but you know both sides had Advocates
and um then there were the people that
were you know we're more in the middle
of trying to figure out either way what
was actually you know the best ruling of
law in this case
uh nice n-e-i-s
yeah
uh Sophia
with a pH Nice N Eis
I'm 23.
uh just graduated students
questions
[Music]
girl
perfect
thank you
[Music]
guys
now obviously
thank you
foreign
you can't be there if you're not in
house press this is the in-house press
only
um
how you doing guys
you're right oh shall I put that on
kind of life
um
do I smoke
[Music]
right um Doug why don't you just come
here
just come around here go there
go there
sorry he's my guys
uh right uh good morning afternoon
everyone thanks so much for uh being out
here
I'm obviously very happy with the
outcome of the case and it looks like
I'm not having to retire from my day job
after all but at the same time I'm
unbelievably frustrated that basis
claims like this are allowed to go to
court at all we've spent the last eight
years talking about two songs with
dramatically Different lyrics Melodies
and four chords which are also different
and used by songwriters every day all
over the world these chords are common
building blocks which were used to
create music long before Let's Get It On
was written and will be used to make
music long after we are all gone they
are in a Songwriter's alphabet our
toolkit and should be there for all of
us to use no one owns them all the all
the way they are played in the same way
that nobody owns the color blue
unfortunately unfounded claims like this
are being fueled by individuals who are
offered as music experts in musical
analysis in this instant the other
side's musicologists left out words and
notes presented simple and different
pictures as Melody and by doing so
created what I think we proved for all
to see were misleading comparisons and
disinformation to find supposed to limit
similarities where none exist and I
think we proved for all to see that they
tried to manipulate Mai and Amy's song
to try and convince the jury that they
had a genuine claim I'm very grateful
that the jury saw through those attempts
this may seem this seems so dangerous to
me both potential claimants who may be
convinced to bring a bogus claim as well
as those songwriters facing them it's
simply Wrong by stopping this practice
we can also properly support Genuine
Music copyright claims so legitimate
claims are rightly heard and resolved
if the jury had decided this matter the
other way we might as well say goodbye
to the creative freedom of songwriters
we need to be able to write our original
music and engage in independent creation
without worrying at every step of the
way that such creativity will be will be
wrongly called into question like
artists everywhere Amy and I work hard
to independently create songs which are
often based around real life personal
experience it's devastating to be
accused of stealing someone else's song
when we've put so much work into our
livelihoods I'm just a guy with a guitar
who loves writing music for people to
enjoy I am not and will never allow
myself to be a piggy bank for anyone to
shake having to be in New York for this
trial has meant that I've missed being
with my family at my grandmother's
funeral in Ireland and I will never get
that time back these trials take a
significant toll on everyone involved
including Catherine I want to thank the
jury for making the decision that will
help protect the creative process of
songwriters here in the United States
and all around the world I also want to
thank my team
these guys who've supported me
throughout this difficult process and to
all the songwriters musicians and fans
who reached out with messages of Support
over the last few weeks and finally I
would like to thank Amy neither of us
ever expected that nine years ago from
our wonderful writing session that we'll
be here having to defend our integrity
Integrity Amy I feel so lucky to have
you in my life thank you
we need songwriters that and the wider
Community to come together and bring
back Common Sense these claims need to
be stopped so the creative process can
carry on and we can all go back to
making music and at the same time we
absolutely need trusted individual
individuals real experts who help
support the process of protecting
copyright thank you
great
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Leave it to these
guys now I've made mistakes
guys thanks guys
[Music]
I think they're tired of us and that's
okay
are there any questions for the legal
team
what do you say to those future
um possible are you guys involved in
those cases as well or we are involved
in those cases as well we will deal with
those cases as and when we have to we
think they have as little Merit as this
case had and we think the outcome of
those cases will be no different
I think the ruling today proves exactly
what it said Ed Sheeran and Amy Lodge
independently created Thinking Out Loud
they didn't copy anybody there was no
similarity between the songs and that's
not going to change in any other case
involving those songs
can you talk a little about what this
case had the potential of doing and do
you think that you what do you think
talked about today is when well I'm
hopeful that today's ruling gives
songwriters more comfort that they can
continue to create great music using the
basic building blocks that were at issue
in this trial with a little less fear of
claims against them
for sure
so it's Eileen
i-l-e-n-e Farkas F like Frank a-r-k-a-s
like Sam you want mine too the real one
the real name Don
zacharin z-a-k-a-r-i-n
that case is waiting on what happens
with the other the first SAS case again
as I said we never thought it had any
Merit we never thought the SAS case has
any Merit and we'll deal with those
cases sequentially when they come up
there's no question that is the law the
copyright office says that's the law
it's not just the ninth circuit it has
always been the law unlike most people
I've been practicing since before 1978
when the copyright law changed so I know
what it was and I know what it is
no not at all
thank you thank you thanks a lot
happens again